so don't cover we're very pleased to be
able to announce that we have just
adopted draft council conclusions with a
view to considerably reinforcing our
combined fight against terrorism we need
to strengthen controls on our external
borders let me remind you that the
current legislative framework already
allows for us to carry out systematic
and coordinated controls including on
people who enjoy free movement we've
talked enough now it is high time for us
to start implementing our decisions it's
not an option it's an obligation grupo
de la république late as the President
of the Republic said to the Congress
meeting in versailles france will do
whatever it can to destroy terrorism the
Europe Europe that we love the Europe
that we have built agonal should also do
what it can to combat terrorism the wall
the model we had asked and we obtained
that the EU P&R directive be adopted by
the end of the year and that it should
be an operational and effectively tool
which will allow us to trace the
movement of people who seek to attack us
intra-european flight sir what should
also be included in the P&R in the
period of for retaining information
prior to the masking should be fairly
long one year and not one month as the
parliaments ali bey committee wanted
because this is a tool that our services
have to be able to use especially our
anti-terrorist services we are all
concerned about the quality of the
judicial cooperation we've also been
able to mobilize the European Arrest
Warrant which is a very useful
instrument which can be implemented very
quickly and is very effective and at a
request on a Sunday Belgium
who tied a European Arrest Warrant to
mobilize the European police forces